quel en france il ya mois disparaissait
la petite estelle la sortie de l'école
depuis le travail des inspecteurs et les
moyens mis en place ont été
considérables mais aucune trace de la
fillette de 9 ans l'émotion et
l'inquiétude grandit un peu plus chaque
jour dans le petit village de guermantes
yves martinet bruno bini disparu depuis
un mois aujourd'hui
un mois durant lequel les parents des
stèles ont tout fait tout essayé d appel
à témoins d'abord affiché partout en
france mais aussi un site internet grâce
auquel une immense chaîne de solidarité
a vu le jour
malgré ses moyens toujours rien ça fait
un mois qu'on a aucune aucune piste
aucune information aucun élément nouveau
aucun élément matériel aucune idée sur
laquelle on puisse asseoir notre action
donc on est face au vide total donc
c'est ce que j'ai dis je c'est une
excellente forme de torture côté enquête
les policiers ont passé les environs au
peigne fin
sondé plusieurs étangs procédé à un
millier d'auditions avant de
s'intéresser à tous les délinquants
sexuels connu dans la région
dix personnes ont été placées en garde à
vue en vain à guermantes la population
encore choqué vacille entre crainte et
espoir
les gens parlent toujours ce fossé
toujours beaucoup de questions ça c'est
certain mais bon on tourne un peu en
rond on a beau se poser plein de
questions
on voit vraiment pas ce qu'il y'a plus
passer devant
non j'ai peur que ça ça set ça s'atténue
tout doucement et qu'on arrive à oublier
et ça faut pas oublier les initiatives
pour retrouver estelle se multiplient
prochainement une association verra le
jour et dans la semaine c'est ta fiche
de 4 mètres par 3 sera placardée sur un
millier de panneaux publicitaires